we provide smart rental units in
apartment buildings in neighborhoods and
offices
where tenants can practically download
our app and rent whatever they want
[Music]
all right yeah alzheimer thank you so
much for joining us for 20 minutes
leaders
thank you so much for having me michelle
so you're original you're originally
from israel but you live in new york and
now you're visiting israel
yeah that's right i'm here for a month
but i moved to new york six months ago
and you moved there for your start of
tulu right yeah
okay so what is tulu talk to me about
tulu um so tulu is an on-demand rental
service
we provide smart rental units in
apartment buildings in neighborhoods and
offices
where tenants can practically download
our app and rent whatever they want for
as long as they want
so we work mainly in residential
buildings in manhattan
we also have 10 locations in tel aviv
some student dorms
uh we're now launching a location with
weeks uh so employees can actually
rent something after work and return it
the next day or for the weekend
um but really our mission is to reshape
the way people use and consume stuff
okay so it's the idea of renting stuff
what stuff are we talking about is this
like
you know it's like vacuum cleaners and
and bicycles is that
the sort of stuff we're talking about so
it's a wide range from what you really
need
and what you kind of want but you know
don't need
um which also makes sense to rent so we
have a dyson vacuum cleaner and we have
a ladder and a drill and a projector
and a steamer so the essential stuff for
a home
uh so household items but we also have
fun stuff like a vr headset
a drone wow sewing machine um and we
just have a very eclectic
so we always have the essential products
that we know people are using and then
we also try pop-up products and
pasta maker mixer air fryer so so
yeah one of the key things that i think
unifies all of these things together is
that all of them break
right all of them are bound to break
points so how does that even work so so
you go to these
apartment buildings you i'm guessing you
have a room where you're putting in all
these supplies
and then something breaks what do you do
so actually when our users break
something we
just ask them to tell us uh and um and
then we'll repair it so our philosophy
is um
is to really try to repair everything we
can or to provide products that are
higher higher quality
um and we know from our users also that
you know they they rather use a really
good projector but they're buying a bad
one from
you know from online because they don't
want to spend the money so our stuff
don't really break
um and if someone um hurts it on purpose
uh which
almost never happens we i kindly just
take it and
and take a deep breath and understand
that it's part of educating a market
right so okay so educating a market talk
to me a little bit about this at this
idea
and and it's not very you know it's not
very conventional this idea that you
have an apartment building
and you have all the tenants share the
same dice dyson vacuum cleaner
and so what what is where did this come
from and what are the different
challenges and
sort of educating the market for that
so actually tulu is uh ever since we
started tula my co-founder is shai and i
um and we have an amazing team here in
israel and in new york
people are telling us this is such a
simple idea and and it had to happen
um but what we're doing that is
different is we're providing access
to a really highly maintained household
items
we're choosing our products carefully
and it's very aesthetic and and it's a
product
it's something um that really wants to
be a part of your lifestyle and create a
habit in your lifestyle
um so starting from our design and our
data and our our marketing everything
is it's just like a brand but in your
building and it's just like a gym or a
pool it's an amenity you have
something you can use in your life in
the building
but also now you know as i told you we
have other
ideas regarding the workplace and
regarding uh neighborhoods
uh around sharing stuff but the sharing
idea is not new like you said
um you know people tried doing
peer-to-peer rentals
um and what we figure is that the access
economy is just
just makes more sense yeah so i mean i
mean the whole
idea of sharing goes back all the way to
the days of the kibbutz right during the
inception of israel and
they say okay let's share a lawn mower
across the hockey boots we don't need
each person to to buy their own
but this also speaks a pretty close to
what i believe
wework started a few years ago called we
live right and then others have picked
up
on this idea of of shared living spaces
and the fact that the new generation
might be more open to the idea of of
you know reducing privacy more sharing
more social interactions
so where does that fit into this whole
sort of genre and
and the paradigm so actually the meaning
of tulu
is originated from tulu which are
chinese buildings
in china uh it's a very very beautiful
big structure with
micro apartments that the center of it
it's a circular
uh structure that the center of it has
the kitchen the living room
of course it doesn't look like what we
know but um the idea is to really
leverage
spaces in a building where the
individual doesn't need
to own or to have stuff that can be
shared with more
people and then therefore use space
better um
so my co-founder is an architect and i
come from a environmental background
and together we really um
we were really thinking hard about how
how come cities
you know people live so close to one
another and there are
much progress happening in the world of
rentals and co-living like you said
but there's still no like there's no
integration in
in your daily lives like if you really
want to do sharing you have to
move to a william or you have to move to
a like
a kind of a prestige um
living situation where people are living
in buildings right now
they they can still do that um so
as you said the our demographic is
mostly young professionals
uh people that are short on research
that are more adaptive and
and early adapters to the idea of access
um and differently the nike boots we're
using an app
um in a state of mind where like you
know in akiba's if you
if you borrowed something from someone
and they
brought it back dirty like you would get
upset and you would talk to them but now
it's
it's through us and we take care of
everything and you pay ads
so it's uh in a sense it's a bit easier
on the user
um to go through them to the fundamental
process of trusting a company to do that
for you
but we are trying to create a sense of
ownership in a rental world where
if you took your vacuum cleaner you'd
want to return it clean because you know
your neighbors are also relying on that
right and i think it does also speak to
difference on i imagine living in an
apartment building and my name my
my neighbor above my floor comes and
says hey michael can i borrow your
vacuum cleaner mine just broke
i'd say yeah of course here just grab it
if somebody on the street
comes up and says to me hey michael can
i come up with you to take your vacuum
cleaner and i'll bring it back
probably not so much right so i think
there is some psychological
acceptance and the fact that you're
sharing this living building or
or office with other people and
automatically you have something in
common that you're more
apt to to share these more personal
things right vacuum cleaners
you are going on all these different
surfaces and but it's
but how big does it get so how many of
these items
do you actually offer to apartment
buildings or offices
we each each tool unit has around 25
products
um it really depends on the size of the
building so our average size is around
200 units
um and that and then you know we just
decide how many dice and how many
scooters how many printers how many 200
units means 200 apartments in the
building
and then our metrics um you know as a
company is to really engage with as many
people as possible within a building
or within a neighborhood so we also work
with tel aviv municipality
and we have this really cute uh tour
room in the middle of nordau boulevard
where we install the smart glass door
and it's and it's 24
7 and people can just come pick up whole
chairs a tent
uh bike carrier uh sewing machine
different stuff
um and then you know we also calculate
how many potential users we can get
um and that's kind of how we think about
it
that's incredible that's and that is in
tel aviv that's in tel aviv we have
three locations we have tel aviv new
york and new jersey
um and hopefully in the upcoming year
we'll have some more
surprises incredible so what are the
biggest you know challenges approaching
the
this type of you know this new market
you are creating a new market in a sense
right i mean
and this is something that's that's very
different and i imagine that the old
there is a generation gap on accepting
this new customer behavior is there
there is a generation gap um you know
we've
discovered that our product market speed
is actually in student dorms
people that are temporary they're
renters they're they're also
i would love to use it in my dorm yeah
yeah you know like and and the average
millennial
moves every two years so if you're
buying uh crap you don't need
you also have to carry it with you to
the next department because you're cheap
you're like you're you're young you're a
student you don't want to buy yourself
well
that's exactly my issue i want to come
back to israel for six months with my
girlfriend but i have all this crap from
stanford that i don't know where to put
so friends have graciously offered to
host it but it sucks because
this is stuff that i don't need it's
probably gonna go bad in six months
sitting away
i wish i could just let somebody else
use it and then come back and rent it
out again
for my next year of course it makes
perfect sense
yeah so it's really a state of mind
where um
as young professionals or millennials
our lifestyle are more dynamic we're
moving a lot
um we don't want to be attached to
things um some people
you know like myself i'm a minimalist i
really love the joy of not having stuff
i
it really brings me joy but other people
also find a practicality of it and i
think
when we designed tulu our mission was to
say if we create something that's good
enough that's reliable
that rents you a suitcase when you need
it and and you can rely on it
right that's how we're going to start
educating a market so that's really
um the first stage of tool was for us to
understand that
the building um we have to be in a good
location in the building you know we
have to be in the lobby we have to be
in an accessible place in the building
it can't just be
you know the the roof or the basement
like for us to really engage with the
tenants
but also to really learn about our
demographic um
it's people who move a lot work a lot
the weekends are the strongest
usually so that's um that's how you
educate a market you have to really be
obsessed with um
um integrating in their lifestyle right
so so then
what are you learning about your
customer behavior over this past time
what what are some of the things that
you
that you've been observing some stuff
are easier to rent than others
um some like bikes and scooters and a
vacuum cleaner
and some brands those are easier right
yeah okay what did you say those are the
easier kinds the bicycles and the vacuum
cleaners yeah
because because it's already happening
and um and you really just don't want to
buy something
that costs a thousand dollars and you
really see the value for money we rent
a couple a couple dollars an hour um and
then some other stuff are just a bit
more challenging in how you tell the
story of renting them whether if it's
cooking products or if it's um like more
personal stuff
that are still rentable um so i think
these are some some of our challenges
really learning the curve
of um getting enough products rented in
a month
um changing our inventory and making it
um uh contextual to the life of our
users
if it's a ps5 that just is coming out
you know we'll have it um
and but also uh being aligned with our
mission which is
uh to really always be um in the
frontier of rentals and how how do we
make more people uh
be adapt to it and learn about it and uh
and try it for the first time
so and what is the business model so the
people come and pay me a picture they
come into the room they open the app
they see
a playstation 5 and then what happens
and then they add credit um they can
they can choose a plan and then they
rent it for as long as they want and
they have a ticking clock
um you know you pay by the hour when
you're done we ask you how it went
and um we get you to rent it again
okay so then so you rep you self-report
everything right
we what you you self-report everything
yeah okay that's very very cool and and
then y'all tell me a little bit about
your background because so so you were
you did quite a few projects and you led
quite a few organizations
prior to uh prior to forming to aluso so
where did you come from
i well i'm i'm originally from bercheva
in la vie which is uh the southern part
of israel
i moved to north carolina for my middle
school and high school
uh when i moved back to israel i became
a tour guide in the
army wow it was like hiking for two
years
which is uh very uh privileged um
failing yeah i was i
i was fascinated with nature with um
with everything that's happening
um with climate and i decided to learn
to study environmental science and in my
in my bachelor degree i became an
activist in the field of environmental
justice transportation and then that's
how i started learning about food waste
and also
fashion waste and and consumption um
and these were i guess the seeds but um
only when i was accepted
um into a program at mit um which is
called our generation speaks um
we were in design accelerator for three
months um and that's how i met ishai my
co-founder
and i i it was a year when i was
listening to podcasts all the time about
entrepreneurship
but i never really thought i would do
something myself
i really thought i would go to an ngo
kind of world and hopefully also become
you know maybe a politician and
nothing's really fit but um
quite a different path yeah but i think
i think you can be an entrepreneur in so
many fields
uh just the tech world is you know it's
where it's harvested but you can just
it's a mentality um and when i met shai
um and he and him he's coming from an
architecture
uh background um in in
my background things just kind of
started to make sense and so let's work
together let's create something together
and we really started from um the
problem we're trying to solve and not
from tulu like tulu was just
um an evolution of other ideas we've had
and we
said okay now we know what we're doing
interesting no i think that's amazing
because i think that
really a lot of entrepreneurs they go on
the different paths i'm saying
i have this idea i'm in love with it i
think it's a great idea and now i'm
gonna
i'm gonna force myself to understand
that there's a problem behind this idea
but going through the approach of okay
well the world is changing
and people need to get stuff people
don't
necessarily own the stuff it's expensive
it's cheap it breaks
and there's a problem and now we have
now let's find a solution to this
problem that's exactly how i want to
approach
and start and and what are some of the
what are some of these sort of earned
secrets that you've learned
over the over the past few years running
this thing
and that you wouldn't perhaps you would
go back and say to your
few years younger self uh well when we
started the company
i was still doing my environmental
science master's degree
um and i was like okay i can do that and
that together it's totally possible
and i can also work and um and i think
the minute i realized that i have
besides committing to tulu being my
full-time thing it's also a mentality
like you have to
wake up and go to bed thinking about
something that's really meaningful to
you and you have to commit to it
so i had to leave everything um and and
tailgate scary
it's really scary but i have to do it uh
so this is the first thing i learned
that i have to really
kind of prioritize this and only that um
and
and and when you build something um you
can have a really good idea
but it's about the team and it's about
the people you work with
i mean as being a co-founder or you know
leading
leading something um i can work 24 7 but
um
in order for other people to be aligned
with what we're doing um you just have
to create a sense of togetherness
um which is something we're working on
um
and and personally moving to new york
for that it's just
it's so much fun to see the similarities
between tel aviv and new york
with millennials mainly like we have
such similar uh buyer personas such
similar people that are
adapting and reacting the same way to
our product
and i'm just fascinated and fascinated
with the world of frontal
because i really believe that um you
know going forward with everything
that's happening in the world
and i'm not even talking about the
coronavirus i'm talking about um
the way we act as humans i really think
solutions um that are practical that are
fun that are sexy that are interesting
these are the solutions that are going
to carry people um
to be obsessed with and to want to use
and to want to pay for and i wanna i
just like i decided we decided to do it
ourselves rather than wait for someone
else to do it
i love it so now so where is this going
so now you have the challenge of okay
you have a product
you found a product market fit in some
areas how do you get this now to
millions of people
well you know we're raising some money
um
but um definitely um we are much more
comfortable now with what we're offering
and we know
um you know we know what we're where
we're aiming and we know
what could possibly happen and of course
we've been getting a lot of offers that
are kind of shifting us from
from our original idea but yeah now we
just want to scale
um we're ready to scale ready to expand
um
we're ready for partnerships um so it's
been a lot of fun like we're fantasizing
and also doing together
uh so it's like um it's a lot of fun and
it's and it's really
fun mainly talking to our users and
learning what they need and how it meets
them
you know some people told us if i knew i
had a tool room in my building i would
have
you know come like you know enough in a
simpler way to live in this building
but many times we lunch after people
already have their lease and they
already bought everything
so i think going forward this is like
the chicken and the egg now because
you're entering a market that
the apartments are already filled and
sort of you have to wait until the next
cycle
of of tenants to be able to validate
whether they really forgo purchasing the
items
and and getting them fertile but but you
know y'all last thing i want to mention
is that you have a pretty
interesting way of entering this that
you know most
co-founders they grew up entrepreneurial
went to study you know computer science
or business and and you know they grew
up knowing that they wanted to start up
but
it sounds like you didn't really know
you're going to do a startup right a
target in the army environmental science
so how how is that process like for you
um i remember when i was i had a
different inventor before tulu we were
doing hydroponics on roofs
with a great friend and when i met her
for the first time he told me i was like
what do you do and he said i'm an
entrepreneur
and it was for me like mind-blowing what
do you mean you're an entrepreneur and
he just
it's a thing i'm an entrepreneur and i
went home i googled entrepreneurship i
had to learn about it
i realized you know you can study it in
university um
but and that just kind of sat with me
and then i realized um
you know this if you if there's stuff or
causes that you really relate to
and you want to do something about it
entrepreneurship is a tool
um and and and of course now i'm
surrounded with the tech world and i and
i see people that
they know more about it than me
sometimes um but it doesn't intimidate
me it's just that this is
you know to create an interesting
startup uh
you can come from a very you know it's
just there's such a wide range
that's it there's such a wide range and
i love being there in this range and
having my own niche
um and i've been finding lots of
pleasure talking to other women
uh from an environmental field um
interested in also
doing something like that yeah yeah i
know i i'm y'all it's
very very impressive and it's very very
inspiring and before we leave
i have to ask three words that you would
best use to describe yourself
um i'm their question i think i think
i'm daring
yeah i'm i'm also simple
um and i'm very optimistic
daring simple and optimistic i like that
combination
very very cool yeah best of luck with
tulu
i hope that next year when i'm back at
stanford you'll already be there
and so you gotta you gotta
quickly and and yeah i look forward to
maintaining this friendship thank you
very much me too thank you so much for
having me
bye